on the 4th of December 2005 the body of
a blonde thirty year old woman was
discovered on preswick beach in Scotland
for a split second she was thinking
there is a girl there sunbathing and
then directly he understood that that's
not possible but something else has
happened here she's identified as Annie
Boursin from Sweden and her family are
told Annie died as a result of suicide
only Annie's mother goo you didn't
understand
she had her passport with her so she was
on her way home
why didn't she board her flight at
Prestwick Airport and why was her body
and passport subsequently found on a
desolate Beach half a mile away when the
family went in search of answers new
elements would emerge the pointed not to
suicide but to murder cover-up on one of
the world's most secretive security
agencies
from Sky News story cast what happened
to Annie
subscribe now hi I'm Lula Dougal this is
part one of what happened to Annie and
use six-part series from Sky News story
cast and it begins on Sunday the 5th of
December 2005 on preswick beach in
Scotland it's coming up to 8:30 a.m. and
a man and his dog are walking by the
shore and something on the beach catches
the man's eye they were very shocked it
was in December still for a split second
she was thinking there is a girl there
sunbathing and then directly he
understood that that's not possible but
something else has happened here
when the man moves closer he sees that
the girl is lying face down on the sand
she has long blonde hair and is reading
jeans atop and trainers so he understood
that she was dead and he called the
police and they came very quickly
the police quickly seal off the scene
and removed the dead woman's body from
the beach but two days later something
significant happens the air sure post
December the 7th 2005 it's to do with
this report in a local newspaper an area
of Prestwick Beach was cordoned off for
the weekend after a woman's body was
found washed up on the shore a dog
walker discovered the 31 year old
woman's body about 8:30 a.m. on Sunday
near to Maryborough wrote a police
investigation team quickly sealed off
the area but there are no suspicious
circumstances surrounding her death as
the post went to press the dead woman's
details have not been released the dead
woman is named as Annie Christina
Boursin a Swedish national who was in
fact 30 not 31 when she died but there's
something much more troubling something
wrong with this article down the road
from the beach and up the stairs of this
industrial unit by press Baqir port a
journalist working for the small weekly
publication the Scottish review is
struggling to make sense of what he's
reading his words are voiced by Sky News
Scotland correspondent James Matthews
the most intriguing assumption in the
report was that there were no suspicious
circumstances
it's an innuendo commonly used by the
police to rule out foul play and suggest
the probability of suicide the
journalist who wrote that was Ken Troy
he died in 2018 he never got to finish
an investigation he started into the
woman's death but crucially he left
behind these notes which he uploaded to
the Internet although the results of a
post-mortem on Annie Boursin weren't
completed it seemed the police had
already made up their minds this was the
first of
some disturbing revelations in this case
even though it's 14 years since Annie
was found dead on preswick beach earlier
this year when Sky News producer Robert
Mahar called to the Scottish review
offices where Kenneth Roy used to work
his colleagues simply refused to talk
about the case it's not overly
surprising that Kenneth's colleagues are
unwilling to talk after all there are
some very powerful institutions involved
in this story the police the Swedish
government and the Scottish crown Office
so who was the woman found dead on
preswick beach in december 2005
well Annie Boursin lived in Sweden all
her life before she moved to Scotland in
late 2004 given all this happens since
Annie's death her family have built up a
deep mistrust of authority and the media
it's taken us six months to even get to
this point our first meeting it's June
the 26th 2019 and we're in a restaurant
in Hoover central Sweden with Ali's
mother gu you
a nanny's best friend
Maria young sample despite Annie's death
being reported as a suicide she never
got an inquest Ghoulia's attempts to
overturn that decision started within
days of police calling to her home in
ebrill Sweden she was found dead at age
23 in the morning of that Sunday the 4th
of December and we were informed
half-past eleven in the evening by three
policemen and priests and then as I know
from the documents they put gloves on
her hands and they cordoned off beach
it didn't take many minutes for them to
lift her up and the driver away from
there and then she ended up at
Kilmarnock Hospital speaking via phone
on Swedish radio Maria wood years later
recall a distressing phone call
just hours after hearing about Annie's
death actually the very first day that I
spoke with a Scottish police they told
me that Annie had committed suicide and
it took me several days before I
realized that I actually said that to me
but going through my notes I can see
that I actually wrote down they that
they said to me that Annie had committed
a suicide and that was she was found
Sunday morning and that that was Monday
afternoon that they told me that how did
police arrive at this conclusion of
suicide so quickly I thought that was
very strange because how would they know
there hadn't been a an autopsy at all
fugu you everything felt wrong police
said Annie's bag had been discovered
beside her body inside they'd found
clothes books belonging to a library in
Sweden and most significantly
her passport today Sky News producer
Robert Mulhern is worth kuia at her home
in Sweden the fact that she was carrying
her passport with her you know could she
have made a surprise visit home or was
she her friend Maria was awaiting her I
knew she was coming but I didn't know
when but she had spoken to Maria and she
was she was going to see Maria first
because they were going to do some
Christmas shopping and she had made an
appointment with her hairdresser also
close to where Maria leads so she was on
her own that's why she brought the
library books you don't carry around to
library books for fun if they a and she
had her passport with her so she was on
her way home and I immediately told the
Swedish police everything I knew about
our life
Booya tall police all about the
important dates a nanny story she was
the second of four children born near
the city of Malmo in Sweden on the 7th
of February in 1975 her father was
Hungarian her mother Swedish is about
she's 40 and then there's Beatrice she's
38 growing up Barney inherited her
father's love of music she even formed a
band annie in the wolves with her
brothers and sisters this is her singing
[Music]
Annie could be creative and adventurous
often at the same time I used to say
this she liked when things happen and so
if it was windy
she took her roller skates off because
there's Italy do much faster so that's a
bit symbolic about her life she wanted
things to happen
[Music]
then in 1987 when Annie was 12 the
family moved to so ditalion near
Stockholm Annie finished school and
studied music then she met her best
friend Maria was insolate Elia at a
restaurant with the name Sorbonne it's
an outdoor restaurant in the summertime
where you can eat and you have also an
outdoor pub and very often they have
troubadours or a minor band playing and
the first time I saw Annie she was
dancing on the table dressed in a blue
dress and she had her long blonde hair
flying loose when she was dancing
she was a Viking woman with her long
hair she was broad shouldered and she
was much taller than me she she gave us
very strong and independent look however
she had also soft softer side and and a
bit naive side that made her vulnerable
I think typical of best friends Maria
would come to knew all the things about
Annie that no one else did for instance
she was fluent in six languages Danish
Finnish Hungarian French and English as
well as Swedish and Annie was as happy
hanging out in IKEA as taking in a heavy
metal concert
and Iron Maiden played in Soho and
patients she didn't have any ticket she
went outside just to hear it just to be
Priscilla you know Maria also knew that
Annie was an exhibitionist she suddenly
started to sing in the middle of the
street one day when we were in Stockholm
so I immediately thought this is fun and
started to sing with her I was a bit
embarrassed a couple of seconds looking
around you know you don't do like like
that and then oh so we often sang
together in the middle of street where
we felt for she's very spontaneous after
college
Annie studied hospitality and works in a
variety of jobs but always at the
weekend she sang and played bass guitar
in bounds with her brothers and sisters
this is the only recording we have of
Annie's adult voice
[Music]
stood here on stage in Stockholm the
site her brother Charlie performing this
song her mother GU you says it best
captures her daughter Annie was just
months from moving to Scotland and
ultimately dying on a beach in preswick
an image that jars completely with who
Allie was a young woman who loved to
sing how fun and live wife
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2003 she moved home to save money for
a new adventure later on when we were 13
oh oh really now Annie went with us
because she had already decided to go to
Scotland because she had been that short
mr. Chaney for a village and she liked
it very much as you want to go back this
is Edinburgh Scotland capital my nanny
moved here in the autumn of 2004 she
lived here Linton Court Apartments in
the west of the city
we're here to try and find out more
about Annie's life in Scotland David
Haye is the owner of Linton Court so
this is Morrison Road which is basically
at the end of dal-rae Road only five
minutes from the sort of West End of
Edinburgh Haymarket area Haymarket train
station my dad actually bought this
building as a wreck in the 70s late 70s
and then converted it into flats to run
a service departments basically you know
I don't think I ever personally met
Annie David he didn't know Annie
personally but you know when it was that
she was reputed to be here but he knows
someone who did my name is Jerry Brown
and and in the evenings I used to look
after the reception for them for
incoming guests between 5:00 and 7:00
and then I used to lock up the office in
evening and and how I got a new idea was
that she rented a flat in the in the
building and she used to come down quite
regular but she always said all always
went out I've come back in and if I was
under this should come down in there
early give then have a smoke at the door
and then these days I smoked as well
therefore the same but not so glad I
used to have the odd cigar I know we
would started
we try and have a cigar and shoot up a
cigarette and that's how I got to know
her and she's a lovely girl
I really was very outgoing quite
vivacious very bubbly yes she really was
and she was really trying to get a hold
of English you know to really understand
English danik had got to know Annie late
in 2005 by then she'd done a six-month
English language course and had got a
job in hospitality and she loved working
there not the whiskey Santa you know we
should got the job in this he's over the
moon
I think she's playing happy to be what
she was doing she she seemed time we
anyway she was never ever come in and
said oh I wish I could go home ah
there's nothing like that she was I she
would always tell me almost a rugby club
tonight looking forward to that no I
don't know if she had any boyfriends and
I know baby she said and they always
keen to it into that because Lisa in
this story you'll learn that a rugby
player I'm one of the world's most
secretive security agencies are reputed
to have an involvement in Annie's death
but we're not there yet other than I
don't think she wrote any friends about
in fact that I never never saw any
friends coming about with her issues
never any problem in their apartments
either you know we could get some noisy
people in to fly to Easter of and
parties and things like that but I never
give ideas trouble she was correct I
think she just kept herself to herself
in the flight
after Annie finished in the whiskey
Center in August 2005 she went back to
Sweden before returning to Edinburgh in
October in the hope of getting a
permanent job considering the
conversations they enjoyed Danny trone
was shocked when the police called to
Linton court that December so as I say
that was not David the police came and
said that body had been found we just
couldn't believe it - detectives
particular detectives there wasn't any
univer and then they asked if I could
get access to the apartment but they
didn't to tell us any detail obviously
because I was investigating the police
searched Danny's room for a suicide note
that couldn't find one
who did this vivacious woman as Derek
described her end up in the sea 80 miles
away after Annie died her body was sent
here to Donna Bay's funeral home in
central Sweden but remarkably almost 14
years on Annie's mother GU you and Maria
are following a new lead and among the
first things we did after finding out
about Annie's story was to call this
funeral home when Undertaker gyoon Donna
be told us she was still disturbed by
Annie's death we arranged this meeting
the last time Annie's mother Julia stood
in this room her daughter's body had
just been transported back from the UK
the first thing we did of course was
that we came into the room and we saw
Annie in the transportation coffin and
so all these makeup and that the hair
was missing yeah trying to understand a
drowned body does not look like this
this is the first time Undertaker gun
has broken her silence about what she
saw that day never known being sung or
feared something was wrong Maria Hansen
translates who had told a goon about
Annie's beautiful long hair so the first
observation of the hair made c'n think
the hair doesn't leave doesn't drop from
the body just because you are dead it
was your observation that hair had been
pulled from Annie scalp as well as being
caught or or
you're into not to lift yes on your head
Goodin immediately saw that it wasn't
naturally it was removed it was pulled
off from Anna's scope as well as the
missing here
Undertaker goon identified heavy
bruising on Annie's head and body The
Undertaker's invar Garda in Sweden they
were surprised by what they found when
the opened
Annie's coffin Kenneth Roy Khun Donna
Bay and Leonard Svendsen discovered big
bruises on her right arm and on her side
about the size of a palm as well as
bruising behind her right here Anja
Annie's mother GU you and then I saw all
these marks and I immediately understood
those are not the kind of marks you get
off to death that's rule things you know
I felt that immediately Undertaker gunas
now convinced the missing here and
bruisings is proof Annie was attacked
and murdered and it looked like there
were some impressions around Annie's
neck like this year I'll avenge were
those markings originally recorded as
mention the original no no no no marks
like if she had been strangled yes the
haunting it also had a myriad yeah she
felt that somebody had pressed thumbs
into like when you strangle someone
do your memory who remembers those marks
after likes after thumps this is what
she saw and she's willing to to tell
everybody if they want to know to tell
that in court as well
like the family Undertaker goon is
haunted by the injury she witnessed and
the fact there was no inquest or fatal
accident inquiry as it's known in
Scotland if Annie had indeed died as a
result of suicide then why did she
travel more than 80 miles from her
apartment in Edinburgh to the airport in
preswick and when the family went in
search of answers to that question
new elements would emerge that pointed
not to suicide but to murder coverup and
the CIA
[Music]